in his closing argument to voters before
the midterms John fetterman spoke for
all Democrats when he explained his plan
to combat record inflation
well let's talk about inflation because
that's a big concern for voters what do
you think the biggest cause of inflation
is and should the Biden Administration
be doing more
let's talk about the trillions in
massive tax uh tax cuts to the corporate
tax structure as well true you know
trillions of dollars that have added to
the deficit and and now they still want
to support those as well true I think in
terms of being very serious about
addressing inflation is is making sure
that those rates are brought back into a
line with what they they should have
been uh where they're able to uh fight
uh the the deficit
mm-hmm
now in fetterman's defense that answer
was no less coherent than anything we've
ever heard from Kamala Harris so perhaps
there is a political future for John
Federman after all and by the way that
answer I'm not joking that answer is no
worse than Joe Biden's answer on the
very same question assuming that the
Democrats don't steal this thing and
unfortunately that is far from certain
at the moment
the libs will soon be blaming their
election losses on everything under the
sun fetterman's health and Putin's
Invasion and the mean old conservative
media and on and on they're going to
blame everything but what the polls and
the voters are telling them namely that
the Democrats are poised to lose because
their policies every single one of them
have failed I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Charles Shaw
who says on the Harvard UNC affirmative
action case the question should be where
in the constitution does it stipulate
that diversity supersedes equal
protection under the law the answer
actually is the Civil Rights Act so
there's a great book on this subject by
Christopher Caldwell called the age of
entitlement but that actually is the
issue is that in the 1960s you had this
massive piece of legislation that in
some ways has superseded the
Constitution and set up a kind of
parallel Constitution and a lot of our
political troubles right now seem to be
trying to reconcile these two different
constitutions so uh that that is where
it comes from It's Kind of a Funny
comment but there is a really deep
answer to this that that does explain a
lot of our current political turmoil and
it's why a lot of people they just want
to tune out of politics you know take
the grill pill come hang out with their
family and their friends just Grill up
some great just me when you want to do
that where you're going to go you're
going to go to good ranchers of course
well grocery store meat prices continue
to rise good ranchers as inflation-proof
model locks in your price the day you
subscribe for the life of your
subscription plus you can pause your
subscription for up to 90 days or cancel
anytime you want but you won't want to
good ranchers ships 100 American Meat
born raised and harvested in the U.S
right to your door all of their beef is
prime or upper Choice those are the two
highest grades Superior Steakhouse
quality
good ranchers not only supports American
agriculture they're also big fans of the
daily wire which I love they sponsor all
of our shows I just love them I opened
up my freezie the other day my heart
sunk my stomach dropped because I
realized I was starting to run low on
good ranchers I got to check the time
the date I said when is my next batch
going to arrive I love this stuff go to
goodranches.com use code Knolls at
checkout to get two black angus New York
strip steaks for free
it's an incredible deal you can
subscribe to lock in your price and
recession-proof your meals for life that
is goodranchers.com Knowles use code
Knowles at checkout John fetterman's
answer on inflation was not particularly
persuasive because the man has brain
damage and he can't speak English
properly
don't think that's the only reason why
the Democrats can't answer this question
don't think it's just oh John federman's
health
okay because I am not I am not joking
when I say
John fetterman's answer on that question
which was something vaguely relating to
corporate tax rates
was more coherent than Joe Biden's
answer on the very same question
yesterday
and they talk about inflation
you know we're dealing with a couple of
SEC inflation is a worldwide problem
right now
because of a war in Iraq and the impact
on oil and what Russia is doing I mean
excuse me the war in in Ukraine
and uh think of Iraq because that's
where my son died
the uh because he died
it has to do with the war in Iraq I mean
no it's not it's not the war in Iraq
it's the war in Ukraine I was thinking
of Iraq because that's where my son died
there's so much wrong with that answer
the main thing is Iraq is not where his
son died Joe Biden's son died in America
he was the Attorney General of Delaware
and this is not the first time Joe Biden
has made this flub
and I don't know if it's because Joe
Biden is senile and obviously is
exhibiting the symptoms that many of us
have seen in our grandparents and
elderly relatives of just his memory is
gone he's saying things that are
completely delusional or if it's a facet
of Joe Biden's political career which
has always involved intentional
dishonesty where Joe Biden for decades
now has just lied he's lied about his
educational record he's lied about his
record in the Senate he's lied about
family tragedies he lied about the way
that his wife was killed he I mean in
really bizarre lies and so I I don't
know which it is but does he think that
people don't have Google does he think
that people don't remember this is he
genuinely confused does he really think
that his son Beau died in in Iraq I
don't know either way though the guy
obviously not fit for the job and then
if you even take the kernel of a real
answer that he's giving here which is
that well inflation it's not my fault
it's a global problem because of the war
in Ukraine you would have to say yes it
is and the war in Ukraine is your fault
according to not just me according to
not just the Republicans according to
Vladimir zielinski according to the
president of Ukraine he said that if
Biden had not taken the sanctions off of
Putin's pipeline Putin would not have
invaded Ukraine
zielinski
rightly observes that if Joe Biden had
not actually invited Vladimir Putin to
invade Ukraine and said if it were a
minor incursion then there wouldn't be
major consequences then you probably
wouldn't have an invasion of Ukraine why
is it that Donald Trump's presidency is
the only one in my lifetime or at least
since the rise of Vladimir Putin to
power where Putin has not invaded a
sovereign country
George W bush invades Georgia Barack
Obama he invades Ukraine Donald Trump
Joe Biden he further invades Ukraine why
is that
Donald Trump was the harshest president
on Russia again in my lifetime he
bolstered NATO he got NATO to start
paying more money into its own defense
and reportedly but it's coming from
decent sources
Donald Trump told Vladimir Putin if you
invade Ukraine I'll hit Moscow
and if you're Vladimir Putin and you
hear that
then you've got to think okay chances
are he's bluffing
chances are Donald Trump do it let's say
there's a five percent chance that
Donald Trump because he's erratic
because he's unpredictable let's say
there's a five percent chance that he
actually willing it will bomb Moscow if
I invade Ukraine well that's an
unacceptable risk that even if it's just
five percent that is an unacceptable
risk which is why I think you had
relative world peace I mean for goodness
sakes Trump brought relative peace to
the Middle East no one thought he was
going to do that
he had North Korea backing down
he had even China on on its heels how
did he do that he had Iran on it because
because his foreign policy was
unpredictable because he would say I'm a
dove I'm running against War the George
Bush wars were terrible and then out of
the blue he goes and and takes out the
top Iranian General
well I'm not going to fight I'm not
going to launch this missile I'm not
going to respond to an attack on saudi's
aramco I'm not going to and then out of
the blue he drops the mother of all
bombs you know he it's just that
unpredictability does it Joe Biden was
easily predicted Vladimir Putin played
him like a fiddle so yeah sure you can
even blame inflation on foreign policy
you can also blame it on Joe Biden
shutting down American domestic oil and
gas production not issuing new federal
leases shutting down the oil pipelines
you can definitely blame it on that you
can blame it on all sorts of of Biden
specific domestic policies but sure you
blame it on foreign policy that's still
Joe Biden's fault so they've got nothing
going into this election the voters know
it Dr Oz in Pennsylvania
this is going to be one of the pivotal
races that determines the balance of
power in the U.S Senate just picked up a
big endorsement the Pittsburgh
Post-Gazette which was for a long time a
left-wing paper now the editorial page
is a little more right wing well they've
come out they've endorsed Dr Oz
they say despite a turbulent Senate race
Oz is better prepared to lead
and they say by the way it's not just Mr
fetterman's Health they write Mr
fetterman's Health he suffered a serious
stroke in May is not the issue his lack
of transparency however in refusing to
release his medical records is troubling
it suggests an Impulse to conceal and a
mistrust of the people
all candidates for a major elected
office should release their medical
records as did Mr Oz
if you want privacy don't run for public
office and then they point out that Mr
fetterman's life and experience and
maturity are also concerns he's never
held a real job he's been getting an
allowance from his family his entire
life he he was the mayor of a tiny
little town of 2000 people it's just he
just doesn't he isn't prepared for this
he's not ready for prime time and it's a
really good point here because
I think that the Pittsburgh Post-Gazette
overstates it I do think that if a
candidate suffers a major stroke that is
a very serious concern I if you if you
if your brain isn't working then you
shouldn't be in the U.S Senate you
should go and get better if you can get
better and then maybe try again but but
they are right that it's more troubling
even than fetterman suffering a stroke
is the cover-up
the cover-up is almost always more
troubling than whatever the actual
incident or accident or crime even in
some cases is
because
had fetterman come out
at the campaign said yeah this guy had a
stroke he's recovering we're going to
keep him off the campaign Trail but
Democrats need to hold the Senate and Dr
Oz is a slimy Republican and he's
friends with Trump and he's really
really bad I actually think fetterman
probably would have had a better shot in
this race
but the fact that the campaign just lied
and pretended the whole time oh
fetterman's fine his recovery has been
amazing and then they put him on stage
and he can't speak English well that's a
shock to voters and probably one of the
reasons why fetterman at least today is
probably poised to lose
I think that it's pretty clear at this
point the Liberals at least believe that
they're going to lose in the midterms
and here's my strongest evidence for
this yet it's not just the polls it's
not just the preemptive excuses for
their losses it's something I saw
yesterday I was driving up to Kentucky
I was giving a speech last night at the
University of Kentucky on all all the
crazy conspiracy theories conservatives
have believed all of which turned out to
be true you can catch that speech on the
yaf YouTube channel it's the difference
between a conspiracy theory and the
truth is the name of the speech answer
of course about three to six months so
I'm driving up there and I'm scrolling
through my Twitter and I see a big
warning pop up and the warning says it
takes time to count all the votes don't
expect results on Election night I
thought here we go again here we go
again they're going to try to steal it
it's really really frustrating because
we're just trying to send good people to
Washington DC when you want good people
for your business when you want to take
care of all the HR concerns that come
along with Personnel you've got to check
out Bambi right now go to bambi.com
Michael when running a business you get
hit with all kinds of interesting
scenarios let's say an employee doesn't
show up to work on time or you get a
wrongful termination suit one complaint
can destroy your entire company the
problem is HR managers are expensive
they can easily cost over eighty
thousand dollars per year but with Bambi
you get access to your own dedicated HR
manager starting at just 99 a month all
of Bambi's HR managers are based in the
United States and can support the
nuances across all 50 states your
manager is available by phone email and
real-time chat to help you effortlessly
run employee onboardings and
terminations encourage good performance
and make sure your business stays
compliant with ever-changing HR
regulations with Bambi's HR autopilot
you can automate the most important HR
practices such as setting policies
training and feedback in fact the MB
clients are four times less likely to
have a complaint filed against them
really good news go to bambi.com Michael
right now type Michael Knowles when you
sign up that will really help the show
that is
b-a-m-b-e-e.com slash Michael type in
Michael Knowles here we go again
here we go again
it takes time to count all the votes
it's expected to take multiple days to
count the votes so the projected winners
of some elections might not be announced
yet this means you could encounter
unconfirmed claims that a candidate has
won their race find out more is the
button underneath that post and then
learn how voting by mail is safe and
secure
this is what Twitter is telling me
already
biggest because Twitter knows that the
conservatives are poised to win not
nothing
that Twitter said in that post is true
that whole post is fake news it doesn't
take time to count all the votes
Brazil was able to count all the votes
in one night
on Election night
they got the results they know who won
the presidential election
for my lifetime
pretty much every election was settled
on Election night there were some
exceptions when it was really really
close
but right now according to the polls a
lot of these elections are not going to
be really really close so why is it
going to take forever and ever to count
how come it's only since 2020. how come
it's only since the Democrats became
fanatically obsessed with keeping Donald
Trump out of political office by any
means necessary that America can't
conduct elections then it oh it just
takes days and weeks don't you oh it
always takes days and weeks to count all
the votes how come it never took days
and weeks for my whole life until 2020.
and then they changed all the voting
rules and now it takes a little while
because Democrats need to you know well
first first the Democrats need to count
the votes
and then they need to figure out how
many more votes they need and then it's
going to take days and weeks and a few
broken water pipes to figure out how
they can get those votes in and then
magically all of a sudden the numbers
change and the Democrats win it's
ridiculous it's so transparent
and yet if you raise any questions about
that you're the crazy conspiracy
theorist
because as I mentioned in my speech last
night all conspiracy theorists means is
just
shut up it's this it's the same as
racist when people call you a racist
what they're real they're not saying
that you have any particular views on
Race that are that are disreputable
they're just saying shut up shut up I
don't like your opinion shut up you're
criticizing Barack Obama shut up you're
a racist
you're criticizing George Soros shut up
you're a specific kind of racist you're
an anti-semite
oh you think hold on you think that just
because we changed all the election
rules to Advantage the Democrats in some
cases illegally and then we actually
bragged about how we rigged the election
in a Time magazine article you think
that we rigged the election oh you're a
conspiracy theorist oh you think that we
ought to be able in America allegedly
the greatest democracy in the history of
the world you think we ought to be able
to conduct our elections and know who
won the elections on Election night oh
you're a crazy conspiracy theorist no
the Democrats are trying to steal the
election that's what it is
let's call it like it is folks all right
it's not even election day yet we're a
week out and they're already pulling
this stuff why because they know that
they are losing but they've got bad news
on this
there's bad news specifically coming out
of Pennsylvania
because the Pennsylvania Supreme Court
just dealt a real big blow to the people
who want this election count to go on
for weeks so that they can stuff it with
Democrat ballots the Pennsylvania
Supreme Court just ruled that the state
must not accept undated mail-in ballots
so this this was one of the big issues
in 2020. a big point of contention is
you had the Democrats make a big deal
out of kovid so that they could shut
down the economy and and get rid of
Donald Trump and change all the voting
rules to make it easier to get rid of
Donald Trump and one of the big issues
was okay we're gonna have widespread
mail-in ballots in the case of
Pennsylvania it was it was
unconstitutional but we're going to do
it anyway and then people are going to
mail in their ballots or they can drop
them off at these completely unsecure
drop boxes in the middle of nowhere in
some cases and then we're going to count
all the ballots and it's going to take
days and weeks but the problem was in
some cases the ballots didn't have a
postmark so you didn't know if the
ballots were actually cast by election
day
even if you believe that we should have
widespread mail-in ballots which is
absurd and Barack Obama was talking
about how this was an opportunity for
fraud 10 years ago now he's pretty quiet
about that but even if you believe in
the widespread mail-in ballots
surely you don't think that you should
be allowed to cast a ballot after the
election
right
unless you're the most corrupt Democrat
in the world and you legitimately
believe that democrats should be allowed
to vote until a Democrat is elected we
have to say okay
election day that's the end what happens
when you get mail-in ballots that don't
have a date on it
well the libs say they have to be
counted because those ballots are very
likely fraudulent and are just intended
to stuff the box for the Democrats
but if you're a reasonable person you
say okay those can't be counted so now
the Pennsylvania Supreme Court has said
no
this state cannot count those ballots
are they going to do it anyway as the
Secretary of State and the the corrupt
liberals who who actually are are
running the elections are they going to
count them anyway maybe I don't know I
mean the crazier things have happened in
elections
but at the very least we now have a
voice from the highest court in the land
in Pennsylvania saying no you cannot do
this but it's a line from FDR
FDR and it's outlined in Robert carrow's
excellent biography sort of gigantic
biography of of uh LBJ LBJ was running a
race he thought he was doing very well
at the last minute he loses the race and
FDR said you did everything right but
you forgot to sit on the ballot box
it's an amazing moment because it's one
Democrat president who made himself
essentially a monarch a guy who was King
who upended the precedent of only
serving two terms going back to
Washington ended up serving four and and
speaking to a future Democrat president
LBJ and saying you didn't cheat well
enough
you didn't realize that what decides
elections is not so much who votes as
who counts the votes
so that's what they're trying to do
fortunately you're seeing a little bit
of a hold up for that right now
meanwhile you look at the polls you look
again at who is voting it's breaking
overwhelmingly for the Republicans
is a new poll out by Trafalgar backs up
a previous poll which shows that in New
York in Liberal New York the Republican
candidate Lee zeldin is leading Kathy
Hogle again it's not a gigantic lead but
we're talking about New York here folks
the Republican has a 48.4 percent over
47.6 percent lead
four percent of Voters still undecided
so it's anybody's race but the
undecideds are breaking Republican and
before you tell me that this Trafalgar
poll oh it's right wing propaganda
Trafalgar is a conservative Outlet
the Trafalgar poll
oversampled the Democrats
in a line with the New York voter base
but they were very very uh generous to
the Democrats here Democrats made up
more than half the sample and outnumber
Republican self-identified Republicans
nearly two to one Independents make up
the other 18.9 percent of this poll
according to Pew research which is not a
right-wing Outlet those numbers roughly
tracked with the demographics of the
state and it what it what is it
indicating it's indicating that it's not
just the undecideds that are they're the
the independence rather that are
breaking for zeldon and the Republicans
breaking for zeldon it's even undecided
Democrats undecided Democrats are
breaking for Lee zeldin so what what do
the Democrats have to say about this
if we know that they want to pull some
Shenanigans if we know that they want to
drag out the voter count like Twitter is
already telling us if then
how are they going to do it well the way
they're going to do it was exemplified
by Joy read on MSNBC they're going to to
doubt the polls they're going to say all
these polls that you're seeing talking
about this red way of looking more and
more like a red tsunami they're fake
polls because
the Republican polling firms are are
running a lot of last minute polls to
skew the polling averages and so it's a
grand conspiracy
here in the United States we're a little
over a week away from our own midterm
elections and if you believe the recent
headlines you would think that Mega
fascism is ascendant if you get past
those headlines and dig a Little Deeper
you uncover an Insidious and seemingly
intentional campaign by
republican-backed polling firms to flood
the zone and tip the balance of polling
averages in favor of their candidates to
create a narrative that Republicans are
surging and that a red wave is imminent
and inevitable
our friend Democratic pollster Simon
Rosenberg has been sounding the alarm
for weeks about this wave of polling
noting that if the roughly 40 of the
roughly 40 polls taken in key
Battleground States more than half half
are from Republican firms or groups
hold on you're telling me that half the
polls
in a country where half the people are
conservative that half the polls are
conservative
wait what oh my goodness I I thought I
thought that all the polls were supposed
to be super liberal that's actually Joy
Reid's argument
Joy Reid is saying this is unfair the
Republicans are cheating and they're
pulling Shenanigans because in a country
where the split basically 50 50 between
the libs and the conservatives
actually if you look at political
self-identity conservatives actually
outnumber self-identified liberals and
progressives by a lot because a lot of
people who break for liberals and
progressives are called themselves
moderates or centrists or Independents
that's that's a digression she's saying
that in a country that split roughly 50
50.
it is wrong for roughly half the polls
to come from right-leaning Outlets
that's amazing that's it's such a
confession that the liberal ruling class
believes that they are the only
legitimate voice that it's the same
thing Joe Biden said half the country is
illegitimate the Maga Republicans are
are illegitimate they're uh they're
they're very presence in the country
poses an existential threat to our
sacred democracy our sacred democracy
threatened by the very existence of half
the people and you think about what kind
of stupid commentary you're getting from
Joy Reid right now that like the mega
fascism oh my goodness gracious you hear
this kind of stupid hyperbolic
commentary from some people on the right
too where everything they don't like
it's communism everything I don't like
is communism but it's that's not true
okay that's why I just call them the
libs you know that's they're Libs some
are more radical than others but they're
just kind of the mega fascism it's just
such stupid commentary and it and they
then they get caught up in these own
really dumb arguments because I guess
they don't hear themselves Joy reads
argument is that we we shouldn't have
polls that reflect the voter makeup of
the country why because they don't
believe that ultimately they don't
believe that the voters really should
have a say over the direction of the
country because as Joy Reid says half
the country is fascist and they have
they have no role in in our sacred
democracy is it any wonder that their
campaigns are not connecting with voters
is any wonder that the polls which are
by the way even the even the right wing
polls are oversampling the Democrats is
it any wonder that the polls are
reflecting a potential Red Wave
the real answer here
the real answer as to why the Democrats
are doing so bad a week before the
midterms is that their candidates are
bad and their platform is bad and it's
not resonating with voters Kathy hokel
who's now losing to the Republican in
New York isn't that crazy Kathy hokel
got in hot water because during her
debate with Lee Selden she she
couldn't answer any of his questions on
crime why is crime going up in New York
why why are you not getting harsher on
crime and and Kathy hokel said who cares
about crime she said Lee why do you keep
going back to Crime why are you so
concerned with locking up criminals
completely tone deaf can you imagine if
you were a New York voter hearing that
forget about Republican or Democrat
you're just a regular New York voter
who's concerned about your kids not
getting shot on the way to school who's
concerned about your business not
getting looted and you hear the governor
of New York begging you to elect her say
come on who cares about crime what's the
big deal let's talk about transgenderism
come on let's talk about things that
matter like chopping off your kids
genitals uh right it's so tone deaf and
Kathy hokel's doubling down on this
Kathy hokel goes on Al Sharpton's Show
on MSNBC I didn't realize he still had a
show okay whatever she goes on Al
Sharpton's show and she says that the
the concerns about crime
are a republican conspiracy
these are Master manipulators they have
this conspiracy going all across America
to try and convince people that in
Democratic states they're not as safe
well guess what they're also not only
election deniers they're data deniers
the data shows that shootings and
murders are down in our state by 15
percent even in New York City down 20
percent on Long Island where Lee zeldin
comes from and it's the it's the depth
it's the Republican states where they
have almost no restrictions on guns
because of the abundance of guns people
are killing each other with more
frequency the safer places are the
Democratic states okay lots of lots of
Deceit in Kathy hokel's answer here so
first she says these concerns about
crime it's a total conspiracy because
the data don't back it up which is she
says actually shootings and murders
they're down in New York now that could
be true but but it's it's kind of like
when Joe Biden says inflation is down
this month
hold on inflation is still up so what do
you mean and what does he mean when he
says inflation's down this month Oh you
mean it's down from the all-time record
high last month okay well if gas is down
I'm just pulling numbers out of the air
but they're reflective of the broader
Trend if gas is down five cents this
month over last month but it's up a
dollar over when you took office then
you can't tell me inflation is down
inflation is still up and so if you're
telling me shootings and murders are
down from the past couple of years when
BLM and antifa were just running
roughshod committing acts of terrorism
all over the country I might believe
that
but if you're telling me that crime is
not a problem right now in New York
that's just insane
I mean we know but by the way it's not
as though shootings and murders are the
only crime you just look at robberies
for instance robberies are up 33 in New
York this year year over year according
to police statistics and and she makes
this point she says that actually crime
is a red State problem
you're only seeing the murders in the
shooting is really spiking
in the red states which technically is
sort of true but it's missing the point
because it's not that they're up in the
red States they're up in the bright blue
cities in the red States Rafael mangual
at the Manhattan Institute has a good
analysis of this in FBI in in 2019
where we have the data from the FBI the
the report showed the state of uh
Louisiana as seeing 544 murders that
gives it a murder rate of 11.7 per 100
000. okay so what does that does that
say we've got a big murder problem in
the red States no because New Orleans
which is extremely lib saw 121 of those
murders Baton Rouge super lib had 70 of
those murders Shreveport super lib had
35 of those murders all had Democrat
mayors
so when you take that into effect
just those three cities had a murder
rate of 28.1 per 100 000 if you take
those cities out then the Louisiana
murder rate drops by 29 so it's a it is
a Democrat issue and of course it is you
don't you don't need to be an egghead
going through all the the accounting
books and all the statistics to know
that the Democrats came out and where
the Democrats had political power they
defunded the police they said they were
going to defund the police they said
they wanted to defund the police then
they did defund the police and guess
what happened crime went up big surprise
big surprise it's amazing that people
very often get exactly what they ask for
and this became a huge problem and the
Democrats knew that defund the police
and Spike crime and let the criminals
out of prison and bail out the rioters
like Kamala Harris and Joe Biden staff
members did during the BLM rides that
that is not going to play in Peoria
that's not popular with anybody because
people no matter their race no matter
their geography no matter their
political ideology they don't want crime
in their neighborhoods they don't want
their families being threatened they
don't want their property being
threatened so the Democrats had to run
away from this you see this now in in
one of their really terrible candidates
Stacy Abrams
Stacy Abrams has been hammered on this
issue of defund the police just like all
the Democrats have and she's she's just
denying it she says I've never wanted to
defund the police I've always been
completely opposed to defunding the
police the record doesn't reflect that
though
I did not say and nor do I believe in
defunding the police he is lying again
and I've never said that I believe in
defunding the police so yes to some
defunding we have to reallocate
resources so yes
there it is so you yes to defunding the
police yeah we need to reallocate
resources so yes defund the police
I've never said I would defund the
police lady we have videotape okay and I
know the Democrats try to memory hole
all of this stuff but we still can get
access to it all right we can work a
little Wizardry on the internet we can
pull it up the people are not going to
be fooled forever
so it's no wonder why why are the
Democrats looking like they're losing
right now it's the polls it's the polls
it's the misinformation it's the Ukraine
it's the Russians it's the Macedonian
click Farms it's no it's you it's you
guys it's you and your terrible policies
that the people are well aware of that
you've been promoting for years that
have failed and that people don't like
and they don't like the policies and
they don't like you and they want to
boot you out of office and the only way
you're going to hold on through the
midterms is if you cheat which you're
also clearly trying to do which you are
broadcasting on all the social media
platforms Twitter specifically but which
you've been broadcasting with your
extremely tight relationship between big
Tech and Federal Government Federal
Government working on behalf of
Democrats as they have for many many
years now
you're trying to do it I hope it doesn't
succeed but don't pretend to me that
you're the voice of the people the
people don't like you speaking of
Clueless women such as Stacy Abrams the
view expressed this this total
disconnect with ordinary voters with
what's actually happening in the country
I know shocking right when uh the the
fake Republican on The View mentioned
the Congressional baseball shooting to
make a point defending Democrats of
course because that's all she ever does
and uh the Democrats on The View
appeared not to even know what she was
talking about
what is on the rise is political
violence and I want to say unequivocally
political violence Left Right Center is
wrong to those in my party who are not
calling this out directly shame on you
this is an 82 year old man he's being
charged with elderly abuse for what he
did and really quickly I was working for
the freedom caucus when the 2017
Congressional baseball shooting today my
bosses were actually targeted at the
time Cruz was part of the freedom course
no it's actually just house members but
um Steve's police was nearly killed yes
um in that shooting the difference is
every Democrat roundly condemned it and
they rooted for his recovery
okay so that's not true there were very
prominent Democrats who didn't roundly
condemnity to root for his recovery one
of them is the Wisconsin Democrat Senate
candidate right now Mandela Barnes who
made fun of Steve scalise for getting
shot and tweeted out a picture of Steve
scalise on a little scooter you know as
he was recovering and it said taking one
for the team I question how people vote
against self-interest but this is next
level he literally almost died on this
hill you know hahaha Steve scalise
almost got shot he should abandon the
Second Amendment so Alyssa Farah's point
is an extremely dumb one but not as dumb
as her colleagues who when she says you
know I was I was working in the freedom
caucus during the Congressional baseball
shooting and Joy Behar goes what's that
and it's unclear from the clip was Joy
Bay Sunny hoston thinks that Joy Behar
was asking what does the Freedom caucus
but it's unclear from the clip it might
be that Joy Behar was asking what was
the Congressional baseball shooting I'm
not surprised I think if you pulled 100
Democrats right now on the street you
said hey what do you think of the
Congressional baseball shooting probably
97 of them would not know what it is
because it was downplayed by the media
because it involved a leftist trying to
murder conservatives but even if she
asks what's the freedom caucus what do
you mean what's the freedom caucus
that's the main Republican Outlet in the
House of Representatives
what do you mean you don't know what
that is and then the the co-host is
supposed to know anything about American
politics says that's the thing Ted Cruz
was in and the poor fake Republican has
to correct her and say no actually
it's just in the house and Ted Cruz is
in the Senate so there's okay hosts of a
major Republic Affairs show there's
there are there are two houses in the
Congress there's the House of
Representatives and the Senate and then
there's there are three branches of
government you know there's a
legislature and these they just don't
know anything they don't know anything
and they can get away with not knowing
anything because the libs have all of
the Power so it doesn't really matter
and because they've destroyed American
Education the people don't really call
them on it but they they can't get away
with it forever okay people recognize
eventually when things are going wrong
when something's wrong in their
government with the people running the
show have no idea what the hell they're
doing and that's happening right now
even people who don't study political
philosophy and you don't have very fancy
degrees and haven't worked on Capitol
Hill they can look around and say crime
is going up the economy is in the gutter
they're trying to chop off my kids
genitals the border is completely
unsecure millions of foreigners are
flooding in we're on the brink of World
War III whoever is running the show I
don't want to hear any of your stupid
excuses about it's Putin's fault it's
the Republican it's the misinter
whatever it is you've got the buck stops
with you you guys have done a terrible
job and we're going to vote you out
while radical gender ideologues decry
the harms of
the girls room in the boys room and
comedy specials and dead named
celebrities and and all the rest of it
kids are the ones who are actually
suffering just recently the FDA issued a
warning that prescribed puberty blockers
the ones that transgender activists
claim are harmless and reversible can
actually cause vision loss and brain
swelling the experimentation on children
has to end to fight back we must Expose
and defend the truth as my pal Matt
Walsh has done in his breakout
documentary what is a woman with over
5000 audience ratings on Rotten Tomatoes
what is a woman is pushing back against
the left's dangerous narratives help us
to keep the momentum going by watching
and sharing the movie go to
dailywire.com Knowles today to become a
member and watch it
speaking of the decline in American
Education
Harvard is on the ropes Harvard and UNC
they're they've been dragged before The
Supreme Court
because a group has sued them for their
racial discrimination in admission
practices
and this has gone all the way up to the
highest court in the land and they're
saying look Harvard you discriminate
against Asians you discriminate against
white people you give an unfair
advantage to black students you have an
unfair advantage to Hispanic students
and this is wrong and it certainly
should be it seems like it should be
unconstitutional seems like it is
unconstitutional but we've tolerated
this for many decades in the country and
it's just wrong it's wrong that people
are discriminated against on their race
it's wrong that a white kid or an Asian
kid or some you know some Vietnamese
immigrant who works really hard and
doesn't come from a lot of money and
doesn't come from a lot of privilege and
just works really really hard is
disadvantaged because his facial
features look a certain way and his skin
is a certain color that's wrong to do
and we all know it and you got to stop
it and the Supreme Court seems poised to
to accept that argument because it's
obviously true so Harvard is fighting
back
they're fighting but they have no
argument I played it yesterday where the
lawyer for UNC was asked by Clarence
Thomas a simple question
what is the educational benefit of
diversity
and he couldn't answer that question
he could he said well the the diversity
is good because everyone says it's good
there's a consensus that it's really
good and Clarence Thomas says uh okay
but you're not
you you're you're telling me what's
popular but you're not you're telling me
what's fashionable in certain liberal
circles you're not telling me what
you're not answering the question what
is the educational benefit the guy
couldn't give an educational benefit and
so now Harvard's trying to run away from
this and Harvard's Harvard is
simultaneously trying to argue that they
they discriminate on the basis of race
and they need to protect their right to
discriminate on the basis of race but
they also don't discriminate on the
basis of race so Harvard tweets out a
fact check it's so amazing it's so
pathetic that Harvard which once was a
prestigious academic institution is now
resorting to the same stupid political
tactics of online leftist commentators
you know fact check whenever they do the
fact check
all that means is it's a leftist opinion
column that is presented with the facade
of scientific certainty and objective
truth but it's not it's just
an opinion over a contentious political
issue so say fact check
Harvard has engaged in race neutral
strategies to achieve the educational
benefits of diversity for decades
hashtag Scottish hashtag defend
diversity
so I just want to take that on for a
second because that is a meaningless
sentence
what does that mean
by diversity Harvard means
uh
deciding which races should be more
represented and which races should be
less represented in the class that's
what they mean they're talking about
race when they talk about diversity
that's what the whole case is about
and Harvard's supposed right to
determine which Races they want more of
and which Races they want less of
but then they're saying they have race
neutral strategies
to determine which Races they want more
of and which Races they want less it's
not possible that is a semantically
impossible sentence
it me it it is simultaneously arguing
for things that are in direct conflict
with one another
then it gets even funnier because I
clicked on the stupid fact check leftist
opinion column from from Harvard and you
go in there and it says you know blah
blah blah we totally we we we're totally
constitutional we're following Supreme
Court precedent they say Harvard's
consideration of race neutral
Alternatives follows the law race
neutral
for several decades Harvard is engaged
in race neutral strategies to achieve
the educational benefits of diversity
which they never list by the way they
never can explain what the educational
benefits are because there aren't any
including several suggested by the
expert and the people in the in the
group bringing the case
Harvard eliminated and then reinstated
its early action program when it found
that the elimination of early action was
hindering efforts to achieve racial
diversity
but is that that's not race neutral
that's obviously taking race into
consideration
uh if and then here's the key if Harvard
stopped taking race into consideration
as one factor in its admissions process
and adopted the race neutral
Alternatives that that the organization
bringing the lawsuit suggests the result
would be a class that fails to achieve
the diversity and Excellence of Harvard
seeks so there you have it it's
misrepresented in the Tweet Harvard is
saying we of course we have race neutral
policies but then when you click the
link they're saying we tried race
neutral policies and we don't like them
because we want we want racist policies
if the word racist means anything it
means this it means what Harvard is
doing
we're going to Advantage certain races
and we're going to disadvantage other
races on the basis of their race
they say we don't want that because then
we won't get the racial diversity and
Excellence that we seek
but which is it which do you want
there those are separate categories
diversity and Excellence they're
separate
Harvard is trying to argue that they're
the same if they're the same you would
use the same word if they were the same
you wouldn't need to list two different
categories
they're obviously distinct categories
if diversity were synonymous with
Excellence then Harvard wouldn't need to
worry about diversity because if they
just prioritized Excellence you would
get the exact racial makeup that Harvard
wants for whatever reason
that's not what's happening
that's why they have to disadvantage the
Asian students and the white students
that's why they have to effectively
give them a handicap on their SAT scores
and give other races a boost on their
SAT scores to achieve the racial social
engineering that Harvard wants
can't they can't make the argument
because they know that it's racist
so they can so they have to
simultaneously it's just the same thing
that the libs do on on virtually every
issue they say this thing that you
object to is not happening and it's
really good that it is
that's what it's about
not very convincing I don't think it's
going to convince the Supreme Court
speaking of identity politics
is a transgender activist
Jeffrey Marsh he's gone viral I think he
thinks he's a woman
or he thinks that he's neither a man nor
a woman but he dresses sort of like a
woman Jeffrey Marsh has gone viral with
a tick tock addressed specifically two
little boys and girls in which he makes
the argument that there is no such thing
as boys and girls
hi kids there's no such thing as a boy
or a girl and I can prove it so gather
around the family the parents everybody
answer my questions you either say boys
or girls who's usually taller
oh boys okay but you've met some short
boys right you met some tall girls so
usually boys are taller but not always
okay who likes the color pink
girls okay
um but you've met girls who don't like
pink and you met boys who do like pink
so usually girls like pink but not
always
everything you can think of that makes a
boy or makes a girl
is usually but not always
some of them are not even usually
where does that leave you
free you get to like what you like you
get to be who you are
maybe you're even like me and you're not
a boy or a girl
so obviously very confused man and a
very creepy man and he should not be
allowed within 300 yards of children but
his argument is not coherent either
his argument is ultimately
self-defeating it's a nice bookend of
the show you open up with John fetterman
and Joe Biden you end with this guy I'm
not sure who the least coherent one is
the reason his argument is
self-underminding is not because he's
wrong about the color pink he's right
about that some boys like pink some
girls don't like pink it's not because
he's wrong about height it's true there
are some shirt boys and there are some
tall girls that's all true
the reason his argument is
self-underminding is because he
addresses it to boys and girls
and not he doesn't just say hey boys and
girls I'm going to show you that there's
no such thing as boys and girls
but
because that could be sort of ironic or
with a little little wink and a
tongue-in-cheek it's the fact that
throughout the whole argument the
argument relies on the categories of
boys and girls
the very fact that he says there are
some short boys and there are some tall
girls
presumes that there are boys and girls
the very fact that he says some boys
like pink and some girls don't like pink
presumes that there are boys and girls
the very fact that these people refer to
trans women as a distinct category from
women
shows you that there is a distinction
between the boys who think that they're
women they call themselves trans women
and the girls who think that they're men
who call themselves trans men and boys
and girls are different the very fact
that there are these ontological
categories
the libs are right that there is such a
thing as gender expression
of course there is but they with the
thing they can't get away from is that
ontological reality that there are boys
and girls and even if a boy likes pink
and even if a boy is a little bit short
and even if a little boy likes to play
with Barbies or has the sort of
disordered sexual desires that that guy
has
they remain boys and girls because if
they didn't then his argument wouldn't
mean anything
right his the entire point he's trying
to make relies on the very existence of
boys and girls and then denying and
transgressing that thing that we all
know that we that we all can see before
our very eyes
it's it's a very shallow
argument that that he's making
but it's an argument that cannot be made
because if we even have meaningful
language then there's there's no way to
even refer to the things that he's
referring to without granting the the
very existence of boys and girls that
he's trying to deny it cannot happen he
you can't run away from this reality and
it's a problem you see it in its
absolute extreme absurdity on the
transgender argument but it's on it's on
basically every big claim that the
Democrats are making leading into the
midterm elections they're they're making
arguments that just are not resonating
and they're not resonating because
they're incoherent their argument on
energy we have to shut down American
Energy because American energy is really
bad because it's destroying the
environment but that's destroying the
economy and it's causing record
inflation so we need to convince Saudi
Arabia to produce more energy and we've
got to sanction Russia so he stops the
war in Ukraine so that we get more
energy and and so that the global oil
prices go down but oil is bad but oil's
bad in America but it's not bad overseas
doesn't make sense it's where you get
John fetterman on the stage and he says
I'm I support fracking
previously you said you were pose
fracking yeah I uh I support fracking
there's just no answer on for the
Democrats on any of these issues we have
to shut the country down it's important
covet's going to kill us all we have to
keep the schools closed I never said the
schools should be closed I never said
that kovid was that bad the the fauci
ouchy it's totally safe and totally
effective no I never said that that the
fauciatchi was totally safe and
effective no it just it's
they've just they've run out of
arguments and the people know it and
unless they steal this thing the people
are going to tell them
very clearly on Election Day you know
the rest of the show is continuing now
you do not want to miss it this is woke
Wednesday my producer Ben Davies has
lined up and extremely woke PSA that's
really all he's told me about it from
Forbes you don't want to miss it if
you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
thank you
foreign